bonjour je suis Stéphane thyssion
directeur de colonial observatoire des
tortues marines de la Réunion alors
kélonia est un établissement qui a deux
missions principales la première mission
c'est une mission de sensibilisation à
l'environnement sur la thématique des
tortues marines et une deuxième mission
qui est une mission de conservation avec
un centre de soins qui a un agrément du
Ministère d'environnement qui nous
permet d'accueillir les tortues blessées
malades autour de la Réunion ensuite une
fois que c'est tortues sont guéris on
les remet dans le milieu naturel et on
les fait parrainer par des par des
scolaires ou par du public nous passons
à associer conservation et
sensibilisation vous avons un effectif
de 25 personnes sur kélonia qui est
constitué de 5 soigneurs pour s'occuper
les tortues sur le centre de soins nous
avons 5 médiateurs scientifiques pour
l'encadrement des scolaires et du grand
public et puis ensuite nous avons du
personnel d'administration du personnel
de maintenance et cinq personnes à
l'accueil qui sont là pour accueillir
les touristes et les visiteurs sur le
centre de colonies
donc sur quelonia nous avons une
activité qui est très liée à la
fréquentation touristique de l'île donc
il y a des pics de fréquentation pour
duquel nous avons besoin d'avoir du
personnel supplémentaire pour venir
compléter l'équipe en place donc c'est
du personnel d'accueil vente avec un
niveau bac il faut être bilingue de
façon à pouvoir accueillir des les
visiteurs étrangers et puis au niveau
des qualités il faut avoir une bonne
présentation et une capacité de travail
en équipe de façon à s'intégrer
rapidement au sein de l'équipe en place
pour être opérationnelle et puis d'avoir
une bonne expérience sur ce qui est le
milieu marin et le milieu de la réunion
de façon à pouvoir faire passer les
informations sur les tortues marines et
sur les richesses naturelles de la rime
le personnel d'accueil-pente doit
gérer l'accueil de la clientèle
être capable de travailler en équipe
maîtriser les outils de bureautique
avoir une présentation irréprochable
donc ce qui est important pour les
candidats de façon à sortir un petit peu
du lot c'est d'avoir une bonne
connaissance sur les activités de
péloniade savoir quels sont les actions
et les missions de kélonia et puis il y
a aussi un plus c'est comme les tortues
marines c'est important d'avoir voyagé
et d'avoir des expériences un petit peu
ailleurs qu'à la Réunion ça permet
d'avoir une bonne ouverture d'esprit et
d'autres références qui sont un plus
pour ce genre de travail